what's happening reject nation we're
gonna watch
from a channel called seize the frame a
star wars
fan film been a while since we checked
one of these out kylo ren
versus darth vader this came out quite a
while ago it's gonna be our first time
watching it it's called force of
darkness
let's see what's in store today keep a
lookout for our mandalorian reaction
coming this weekend for the next episode
you know to do that
damn it just hit me that this is a fan
film
that looks so
much like it's from the actual films
hey this looks great yeah this is high
production value
this looks amazing
grandfather
oh
oh i love that galactic empire from
first order
galactic empire my phone going off
it is my phone
raw reaction
there's a reactions height for that
impressive
[Music]
[Music]
works with this guy why are you fighting
him yeah
[Music]
oh man where'd it go dude
this was great still love the roughness
of his
saber against the classic
[Music]
[Applause]
um his effects are great
[Applause]
so sick
there is no escape
[Music]
[Music]
so
now i'm pissed
you disappoint me ben
perhaps you are not as strong as i am
now you'll think you're leaving me with
no other choice
it is pointless
no sound cue
it's not the real darth vader this is
canon
some tests he has to pass or something
right
he's killing the past if he has to
wonder how many people are upset at kylo
ren beating darth vader
oh what a great shot oh
[Music]
sir
we saw you dancing with your lightsaber
sir is everything okay
shut up shut up
that was amazing really well done
it was so good i i felt like that could
have just been a deleted scene
i know that's how good it that's how
great it looks
it really felt like the same location
yeah it felt plucked straight out of
those films
and uh i'm really impressed with that
i'm really impressed with just
how authentic it felt like from
beginning there's only one shot when
one of the stormtroopers moved at the
beginning where you could tell there was
like some weird green screen effect
but other than that one little moment
the rest of it looks
so damn up to par yeah that i
i i felt like i was watching just a
deleted scene
it's a good voice match too especially
for vader
both of them yeah both of them are rock
solid
dude i love the attention to detail too
on the lightsaber fight of how
they both used one hand the entire time
well done alexander chamini
these music that was wildly impressive
yeah my goodness
that's off
kind of harkens back to this came at
2019
okay so yeah i mean it kind of i mean i
think that the first thought that
probably a lot of people will have is
going back to empire strikes back when
luke
thought he was fighting vader cut off at
that
vader's helmet and his face was inside
of the helmet you know so
i think there was like references that
it was drawing from there but placing it
in the
field that would plugs right out of
force awakens
ah so smart so clever
but then yeah like he would fight him
because he doesn't believe he's right
there
but this fight is really with himself oh
and then how he kills the sword trooper
at the end just like that
cold taking out his rage and anger with
him him and being
some raw port to general hux oh man that
was so good that was so good
god and i mean the fighting too like
just especially you know
i mean fan-made lightsaber duels
are are a thing now but especially this
i mean it looked
amazing in the details and everything
yeah
and to see again yeah that rough blade
of his uh
kylo's lightsaber go up against the
classic vader like that's cool
but he brought the mood and tone of life
oh yeah i feel the rage like
boiling underneath there was such a
great
tension throughout
there's cool fan fiction too because
kylo ren wants to be just like
granddaddy vader it's a perfect what if
kylo ren will return
[Applause]
fantastic stuff a plus that's amazing
just get a fan anthology universe going
like there should be just like an
officially
sanctioned star wars fan film
wing that like i don't know find some
way to
align their corporate interests with the
fact that so many like
independent filmmakers are making
terrific
stuff that is up to par with the films
and the shows themselves
yeah i can just imagine being that
stormtrooper though
the hell is this guy swinging at you
what is he doing over there we've been
out here searching looking doing our job
and he's out here
just training with them he's practicing
right now we got a mission to do
damn do that at home man
let's be real though that was a real
vader he would have obliterated him okay
especially if we are doing something
where you're kind of drawing a parallel
between empire strikes back and here how
luke defeated him in the vision as we
saw at empire he lost
pretty damn strongly to him and i mean
it does feel
you know like kind of a missing piece of
context or like it could have like you
said like it could have easily been an
actual
deleted moment maybe you know throwing
on a little bit more context to keep us
all from going wait a minute is this a
fantasy
mirroring that classic you know sequence
between vader and letting us
guess vader and luke and letting us
guess as to whether this is
real in some kind of extraneous way
outside of a canon or is this yeah some
kind of fantasy that could
theoretically fit you know well it has a
you kind of go in that path especially
because
you see the first order then you see tie
fighters show up afterwards and
then vader of quickly appears a little
bit after there so maybe they were
stepping into something like the world
between worlds or
whatever uh some type of forced
connection or something like that there
was just so many great little fam
tidbits there him even calling him ben
was such a rewarding moment too
there's just something that seems so
nostalgic about infusing that element
those voiceover actors were great i
think from the credits there was like
different voiceover actors and different
body performers kind of like the
you probably have a laureen show yeah
main performances and
yeah a couple guys to do the voice over
work but yeah they captured the
atmosphere
perfectly it was a weird weird case
sometimes you watch these fan films and
you remind yourself that this is not
part of the real movie so it's like i
forgive whatever missteps and this was a
case of i have to remind myself that
this is a fan film and not not a real
thing
yeah the cinematography and the music
and everything like they really captured
the look and
feel of those icy forest sequences to
the point where yeah
like some of them also bring in their
own visual style or their own sort of
thing that you might not see in a star
wars movie whereas this felt like yeah
directly tailored around the style
makes the disney films better sure
i wish we could look at it that way i'm
just trying to get
an idea of the purpose of other than it
being like a really cool fan
film with it being star wars and for the
filmmaker's obvious
passion and love for this trying to
gather a little bit more like the deeper
subtext here
of what was really going on
and you know of course there's always
been a clash of
sometimes imposter syndrome with kylo
ren but then
ideologies uh if i'm torn between the
light and the dark and
is this just something that's sort of
playing on that of how he's just
constantly trying to connect with vader
uh and give himself fully to the dark
side i don't know either way i mean
i like how there's kind of this
ambiguous open-endedness uh
towards it but yeah this was this was
rock solid this was pretty impressive
kyla would have definitely lost in real
life versus kyla fight he would have
lost undoubtably he lost to ray a couple
times he uh vader would have totally
whipped his ass
he wouldn't have got to swing in there
right away i mean it was a cool moment
though when the lightsaber came through
him
his but vader would have won
i'm not just saying that so there's
plenty of movies and
a whole bunch of other things to go off
of to support that eddie who
sees the frame make sure to subscribe to
this person's channel or this group's
channel i'm assuming subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell keep a lookout for amanda lauren
reaction last but not least let's do a
john wants to shout out omni media go
for it right what's up michael b
just wanted to send you a little love
and also i mean direct everybody to your
mandalorian reactions as well as your
channel in general you're in our
notifications our subscription feed
and every time i see one of your videos
it just makes me happy to see that your
channel your viewership is growing and i
hope that
i mean this video can help that continue
and then maybe one day you can make your
own star wars fan
film because you're a man of many
talents you can sing
i'm sure you can probably act pretty
badassly so uh
let's get that omni star wars universe
going man that's what i want for
christmas
love it good job john you promoted him
well hi
[Music]
thanks